when Scott and I started working
together 10 years ago I had just gotten
out of sex addict rehab and I was like
man now I got to go back on the road
like dude I'm a dead duck I need someone
to come on the road and and be a
professional [__] blocker honestly like
in the last 10 years on the road I
probably hooked up with like 10 chicks
only ever actually laying down in the
road you're getting [__] on an
on-ramp
yeah those are the 10 you
count only 10 times only 10
times I don't hook up with chicks on the
road really
like I was hired as a [__] block and so
like the first like four or five years
it was nothing I didn't even jack off on
the road while now you're getting crazy
I swear to God now it's getting now I
wasn't even there but I have to object
that's one of the most ludicrous things
I've ever heard in my life